[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france24
históricamente los genitales femeninos
han sido tratados como una muestra de
impudor algo que se esconde que es
desagradable y de ahí la importancia de
resignificar la vulva la vagina y el ser
mujer la invitada de hoy es la artista
brasileña juliana notar y desde el
estado de pernambuco creó su obra diva
motivo de polémica pero también de
celebración del cuerpo femenino y de
reflexión por el abuso al que
constantemente son sometidas las mujeres
aquí la historia de una imagen que viene
exponiéndose desde 2003 con mucho ahínco
en una reivindicación de la corporalidad
una vulva de 33 metros de altura en lo
alto de una montaña de pernambuco es la
obra de julián a notar y la artista
brasileña que llevó su trabajo al parque
artístico botánico usina de arte en las
afueras de la ciudad de recife tallada
con pala recubierta con cemento y
resinas pintada con rojos viscerales
la diva como la bautizó su autora es una
nueva muestra de la poética de notar y
que constantemente plasma recuerdos y
reflexiones en torno al cuerpo de la
mujer la violencia la intimidad la
sexualidad el trauma
pero la hendidura no sólo es una vagina
para notaría representado en el tiempo
una herida que alude también al ano oa
otros orificios corporales y por eso la
viene presentando desde 2003 con
performance como doctora diva en
galerías y espacios urbanos que van
desde brasil hasta varias ciudades
europeas ahora se ve a la distancia viva
ha sido motivo de euforia pero también
de críticas e intentos de censura en un
momento en el que los conservadores
gobiernan el país y en una sociedad que
notar y describe como falocéntrica y
antropocéntrica
nos acompaña desde brasilia la artista
julian a notar ya su trabajo es una
catarsis para ella y para todas para
hablar de nuestros deseos de nuestros
traumas de las cosas que necesitamos
como mujeres y de cómo se nos cosifica
julián brinda a france 24 muchas gracias
y feliz de estar aquí
lleva a juliana es una pérdida es una
performance pero también es un trabajo
de investigación de muchos años sobre la
corporalidad y también es un testimonio
de su propia historia es así
sí sí sí sí la verdad viva ya tiene una
historia porque encontré en un lugar
donde vendían cosas usadas especuló que
son esos instrumentos que introducían en
la vagina de la mujer un ecológico
sí a partir de aquellos instrumentos que
tenían escrito doctora diva que era la
médica ginecóloga dueña de los espéculos
es que yo creé esa performance en la que
yo salía abriendo en las galerías en las
instituciones es esa herida en forma de
bulbo y ahí yo la bañaba con sangre e
introducía el espéculo que yo estuviera
cometiendo en la violación haciendo
violencia sobre esa institución
como si el cuerpo de la mujer se
convirtiera en la arquitectura del
espacio ahí hay una relación muy
interesante que luego nos hace pensar en
el patriarcado en las relaciones de
poder que existen que el patriarcado es
una máquina que opera en todas partes
desde la subjetividad desde las
instituciones desde la manera como
pensamos como desea
cómo se hacen las cosas
entonces esa performance está mostrando
esa violencia en la que el cuerpo de la
mujer ha sido sometido durante milenios
de patriarcado que sufrió que aún tras
esa relación de violencia una herida y
una vulva que carga todo eso pasado y
que es pasado presente muy tristemente
de mucha violencia como el suicidio en
un país sumamente violento que es
extremadamente machista
y eso lo vemos en los números en todas
las instancias desde la violencia
psicológica física entonces este es un
proceso que encierra mucho tiempo un
tute impune
julián abu de trabajo juliana usted
trabaja desde hace muchos años con
doctora diva casi 20 años porque haya
que aínda depresor que cree que aún es
necesario insistir en mostrarles a las
personas cómo es una vagina que sangra
que sufre que es abusada constantemente
constantemente
infelizmente aún lo necesitamos sería
bueno que no lo necesitáramos mostrar
esa vida estar esa violencia demostrar
que todas esas represiones justicia en
torno al cuerpo de la mujer y del deseo
de la mujer de la mujer junto a como
todo
y novato esa es la repercusión de la
obra que ha ido a varios continentes a
varios países muestra precisamente eso
que aún falta mucho camino por delante
es que aínda falta mucho estado por
ejemplo hemos logrado muchas conquistas
a lo largo de los movimientos feministas
con la cuarta ola
vamos alcanzando metas la legislación
del aborto argentina consiguió una cosa
maravillosa en américa latina
pero aún así queda mucho trabajo por
hacer y eso es una repetición muy clara
esa agresividad esa rabia no es porque
es el genital de una mujer no es porque
es el sexo es porque representa a la
mujer entonces a una mujer tiene esa
necesidad de su innovación por eso es
que los hombres no quieren perder ese
lugar ellos no quieren dividir el poder
son esas otras voces la población
transgénero
procesos afrontan a ese hombre blanco y
si es que tal grupo se mantiene no queda
espacio y es una lucha diaria de de
construcción también interno como ya
dije el patriarcado es una máquina que
opera en varias instancias entonces a
veces cuando nos vemos ya seamos
llevadas por esa máquina patriarcal y
nos educan para eso de acuerdo con la
ley del padre con esa división
es un trabajo muy bonito el que ha hecho
con esa cuarta ola feminista
son cosas maravillosas con las mujeres
jóvenes que son un cuerpo de lucha desde
todas partes
falta eso está claro y es la repercusión
de este trabajo la rabia el odio sabes
también culturalmente la sociedad que
nos enseñan bien culturalmente la
sociedad nos enseña que la habana es fea
que no es agradable sentimos vergonya
mismo muchas mujeres no sentimos
vergüenza muchas mujeres si siquiera
saben cómo es su vagina y esto es un
mensaje muy importante importante
y lo es porque existen mujeres que no
saben lo que es un orgasmo y hay mujeres
que no se tocan que no se conocen
entonces es ahí cuando vemos que es
necesario es importante traer esa
historia simbólicamente esa figura en el
arte también está en la agenda del arte
veíamos cómo lo hacían con las velas
y nosotros aún precisamos traer esa
simbología de esta simbología de la de
alexis necesitamos hablar de ella
necesitamos hablar de cómo la mujer
tiene un cuerpo que da placer que no
sólo sirve para la reproducción del
canal vaginal es donde llega el
espermatozoide y hay concepción
esa parte del cuerpo de la mujer es la
única existencialmente hecha para el
placer y eso aún genera más odio más
reclusión a los hombres porque la mujer
es convertida en objeto la chica da
muller colocando para vender es usada
para vender prima es una mujer que
desconoce el orgasmo que es anulado en
todos los sentidos en todos sus
instintos en otras 10 entonces es
preciso hablar de ese empoderamiento
hablar de poner a la mujer en el lugar
de protagonismo con su propio cuerpo con
su propia subjetividad con su propia
visión del mundo su manera de existir de
esa forma manera de existir
una cosa que el gusto muy todo una cosa
que me gusta mucho de este trabajo es
que no solamente hablamos de una vulva
mavuba en humanos una boca es una no es
una boca es un orificio y hay quienes
creen que tiene el derecho a usar el
cuerpo de otro y ahí viene su reflexión
de dolor y de trauma tan importante
trauma tan importante
justamente vázquez ácida justamente yo
creo que la herida que abre esa brecha
para seguir interviniendo y que quiere
el falocentrismo es para los centrismo
detesta todo aquello que es un orificio
sea una no sea una vulva y eso afecta a
la mujer pues ella es una mujer gay a
toda esa población que está fuera del
sistema para los centristas que está
fuera de este pensamiento en un sistema
falsos de entrevista está fuera de ese
pensamiento cuando hace incluso es
cuando usted reivindica esa posición de
esos lugares de esas nuevas formas de
existir porque son otras sexualidades
otras maneras de estar en el mundo que
no son para los centristas o zenttric
anna quien habãa que hay actitudes que
creen que todo el poder
toda esa manera opresora en la que
abunda la violencia en donde la
violencia necesitamos cuando mostramos
que está mal el mundo está viviendo una
pandemia y toda su destrucción es y eso
está justamente ligado a un pensamiento
patriarcal a los centristas de violencia
en hindi
a tengan un límite de creer que la
tierra no tiene espacio creer que se
puede ser discriminatorio con el
territorio que todo se acaba la gente
muere ese pensamiento entonces que es
para lo céntrico que no soporta las
brechas que no soporta esas otras
sexualidades la herida de esas brechas
de esos combates
y muchos niños reflex y muy rápidamente
una reflexión de su país que es brasil
ahora liderado por un conservador como
lo de jair bolsonaro de jair bolsonaro
qué es lo que piensan
peso que es fuego que acontece vamos a
tratos
yo pienso que esto es un retrato de
brasil porque fueron justamente los
grupos bolsón aristas los que atacaron
que atacaron con su moralismo con sus
fundamentalismos con ortodoxos con
evangélicos con religiones y los valores
que dicen que la mujer debe ser sumisas
y salsa jose como agentes de aquí a
ministra neta tenemos aquí una ministra
de las mujeres que es extremadamente
machista extremadamente patriarcales y
entonces tenemos retrasos muy grandes en
brasil y es un momento histórico de
mucho dolor el que se está viviendo aquí
de mucha represión infelizmente que toca
muchas cosas nada de presentismo mismo
mucho y muy natural la economía la
educación hay mucha represión con ese
pensamiento justamente eso es lo que
tenemos que combatir que más que el arte
para eso esa cuesta ese pensamiento una
se enfrenta a las instituciones y es que
qué hace intenta combate
a mí también me han cerrado exposiciones
por eso porque ese ciudadano de bien
moral una moralidad concreta en realidad
y si disney moral amor o hipócrita
porque piensa que puede comprar un
revólver y matar a cualquiera en fin es
un momento difícil el que estamos
viviendo sin allí existe mucho trabajo
muy obligada juliana mucho placer fallar
con busse
ciao y ustedes muchas gracias por estar
con nosotros en ellas hoy nos vemos
próximamente en france 24
[Música]